[Music]
[Applause]
with both the rocky horror picture show
and showgirl celebrating anniversaries
this week
we take a look back at the history of
the midnight movie a midnight movie
isn't just a film you watch at midnight
but films that were reshaped and
reclaimed by how the audience interacted
with them
after their initial release often
through quote along midnight screenings
or creating events or entirely new
musical productions to replicate them
starting with reefer madness all the way
through the big lebowski
join us as we look at some of the
biggest midnight movie successes
for films released in the 20th century
let's do a time warp
reefer madness originally released in
1936.
reefer madness was originally financed
as a cautionary tale that was funded by
a church
group and was titled tell your children
it was purchased in 1938 by notorious
exploitation filmmaker dwayne esper who
inserted a few more salacious shots of
marijuana hysteria
and the former church film became what's
been shown ever since
[Music]
35 years later reefer madness was
revived on california campuses when
normal
a marijuana activist group purchased a
print for just 297 dollars in 1971.
normal started to screen the film as a
student fundraiser for the california
marijuana initiative ahead of the 1972
fall elections despite the revived
popularity from university midnight
screenings there was no copyright to the
film
new line cinema's bob shea who studied
copyright law at columbia university
noticed this and purchased a print to
release nationwide
this move made millions for the emerging
studio that would eventually create a
nightmare on elm street
final destination and many other horror
franchises
night of the living dead originally
released in 1968.
george a romero's idea for the night of
the living dead started by reading
richard matheson's novel
i am legend matheson's story was about
one man left to fight off a world of
vampires
romero was more interested in how people
would respond at the start of the
epidemic
if you're going to do something about
revolution you should start at the
beginning he said
not wanting to be too similar to legend
romero created the dead coming back to
life to attack and infect the living
the film was originally released as a
saturday matinee which was custom for
low-budget horror movies at the time
but there was national outcry because a
rating system did not yet exist
many children purchased tickets on their
own and were horrified not just by the
violence
but the ending which chicago sun times
critic roger ebert noted would be
impossible for kids to grapple with
although the film was a success at the
box office the controversy around the
night of the living dead was the loudest
conversation
around the film its subsequent midnight
movie showings reshaped its cultural
relevance to a parable
about 60s countercultures and the civil
rights movement confronting an america
that was devouring itself
living dead played at midnight
screenings on weekends for years during
the 70s and established new york city's
waverly theater as the
epicenter of cult films which is exactly
why the re-release of rocky horror
picture show was held at the waverly but
more on that to come harold and mod
originally released in 1971
hal ashby's dark comedy concerned a
young death obsessed man who befriends
and eventually romances a 79 year old
woman who's focused on living life to
the fullest
it received many negative reviews from
the largest publications at the time
however herald and mod became the first
hollywood studio film of the 70s
to develop a cult audience of repeat
viewers
this was most notable in minneapolis
where the film played
every day for more than two and a half
years at the west gate theater
stars bud court and ruth gordon attended
multiple screenings over a two year
period
its 1957 screenings at the theater was a
record for most consecutive shows
at the time at its two-year anniversary
screening
some concerned twin city residents
picketed the film demanding variety at
the theater
the obsession in minneapolis led to new
stories and eventual critical
reclamation of the film
broadening its modern appeal was the
loving mention in there something about
mary
no not that hair gel scene but this i
guess i just wish they made movies like
they used to make
you know classics like the karate kid or
harold and marge
harold and mod is my all-time favorite
movie the rocky horror picture show
originally released in 1975. damn it
janet
during the initial release the rocky
horror picture show attracted sell-out
crowds to a single theater in los
angeles
with repeat attendees but it flopped in
the next
eight cities it played in in 1975
causing fox to cancel plans for a
halloween expansion
they did not however give up on it they
thought they could replicate the cult
appeal in los angeles
elsewhere if it's screened as a midnight
movie the first midnight showing was on
april fool's day 1976 at the waverly
theater in new york city where it played
every friday and saturday night for the
rest of the year
the convention of dressing up bringing
props and shouting back at the screen
was solidified by the time the midnight
only weekend screenings
had expanded to 230 theaters around the
country
by 1979. audience participation at rowdy
midnight screenings including dancing
the time warp to the song in the film
and hurling toast hot dogs rice and
toilet paper at the screen at specific
moments
the level of participation born from
rocky horror midnight screenings laid
the groundwork for audiences who
attended midnight screenings of tommy
wiseau's the room
the evil dead originally released
1981-1983
the 12-week shoot of sam raimi's first
film was incredibly daunting
the location had no plumbing some actors
were inadvertently stabbed
it took hours to remove the fake blood
each day and it was so
cold the furniture was burned to keep
people warm on set
star bruce campbell called it a
mirthless exercise in
agony but the road to get the movie in
theaters was perhaps
even more daunting remy first screened
the film then called the book of the
dead at a detroit theater
to help market the event raymie ordered
ambulances to sit outside the theater to
warn potential moviegoers of the
experience
ervin shapiro who was a founder of the
cannes film festival eventually saw the
movie and suggested the evil dead title
as books sounded too boring and then
granted the film to screen at the cannes
film festival
it's at the 1982 canned film festival
where horror author stephen king saw the
film and dubbed it
the most ferociously original film he'd
seen in
ages in usa today this quote was used to
market the film which combined with an
x rating created enough buzz that evil
dead found
wider distribution time warp callback to
reefer madness
new line cinema distributed the evil
dead in a unique fashion in 1983
into theaters and video stores at the
same time
while box office was soft it was video
rentals where the evil dead made its
mark
becoming the most rented title of the
year in the uk
even outselling the shining during its
home video debut
here's ash point break originally
released in 1991
to those dead souls inching along the
freeways and their metal coffins
we show them that the human spirit is
still alive
so you trust me
okay then don't worry about this guy i
know exactly what to do with him
point break was a light financial and
critical success at the time of release
but its cult status grew
in 2003 when point break live debuted in
seattle
this production leaned into the
homoerotic undertones and varied acting
styles that would grant the film new
life
and fans a decade later point break live
is called the first ever
reality play an unrehearsed attendee was
chosen by the audience to play keanu
reeves johnny utah role by reading their
lines from cue cards held by a pa
this is performed opposite a rehearsed
principle cast
via con dios bros and babes this reality
play
sold out its entire two-month run in
seattle and then
toured the country the longest run was
in hollywood where it opened in 2007
and closed in 2016. a production in san
francisco ran for eight years and didn't
sell out on only two occasions during
its entire run
showgirls originally released in 1995.
boasting a budget of 45 million dollars
showgirls was the most expensive
nc17 film ever produced and also the
only
nc17 film to receive a wide release in
theaters nationwide
showgirls was lambasted at the time of
release by critics and audiences alike
it's at the record for the most razzy
nominations you know the awards for the
worst film of the year at
13. it's worse than dog food
it is
had dog food the first seeds of
reclamation were planted in 1998 from an
unlikely source acclaimed french art
house director jacques rivette
rivet called it one of the greatest
american movies of the 90s
it's about surviving in a world
populated by [ __ ] rivets said
adding that it's paul verhoeven's best
american film
showgirls however was an immense success
on home video
where it generated 100 million dollars
from rentals
united artists made new at-home
additions that included shot glasses and
drinking game cards
to enhance the communal viewing
experience
the revived communal experience led to
not just some of the most
attended midnight movie screenings but
also like point break
led to an off-broadway musical
production showgirls the musical
the full audience reclamation of
showgirls wasn't complete until
elizabeth berkley who once called the
reaction to the film
cruel watched the film with an audience
at the hollywood forever cemetery for
its 20-year anniversary
at the event berkeley said tonight is
like this magical full circle moment
where i actually get to experience the
sweetness of the screening
with a crowd that embraced it the big
lebowski originally
released 1998 the big lebowski was
written
in the early 1990s by joel and ethan
cohen with
actors jeff bridges and john goodman in
mind the cohens wrote the script before
fargo but because bridges was filming
wild bill and goodman was busy with
roseanne they waited to shoot the movie
until they were both free
lebowski was eventually released two
years after their critically acclaimed
1996 feature fargo which won two oscars
and set up unfair expectations that
lebowski was going to be another top
awards contender as a comedic riff on
raymond chandler's stories that focused
on a slacker in a modern socal setting
the big lebowski received mixed reviews
and was an initial box office
disappointment however the big lebowski
went on to become the first cult film of
the internet era
midnight screenings at the new beverly
theater in los angeles became quote
along events which once written up
led to the film being booked at multiple
midnight venues from 2000
onward the immense fandom led to the
first ever lebowski fest held in
louisville kentucky in 2002.
the event includes a night of unlimited
bowling live music and numerous costumes
and trivia contests
lebowski fest has since expanded to
other cities including london
ardent fans call themselves achievers a
nod to the little lebowski urban
achievers certificate given by the
billionaire lebowski
but perhaps lebowski's biggest
achievement is having two species of
spiders named after him
the analosum as big lebowski and the
anilosimus dude
could a marmot be next
oh nice
thanks for watching and tell us your
favorite 20th century midnight movie in
the comments below
[Music]
you